optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and I also the personal
question now is see I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton well hello there my dear
little munchkins this is Tim Ferriss
I've had some caffeine since you last
heard from me what you're about to hear
is part two of a multi-part conversation
with Tony Robbins to put it briefly Tony
Robbins is a performance strategist with
clients including presidents like Bill
Clinton mother Teresa not making this up
Andre Agassi Leonardo DiCaprio and Oprah
Winfrey who calls him superhuman this
guy is a force of nature
if you didn't catch the first part you
might want to do that before venturing
in but really we jump around a lot cover
a lot of different topics so if you
don't mind your stories is more of a
jigsaw puzzle then by all means keep on
listening from this point on this
episode is brought to you by 99designs
dot-com the largest marketplace of
graphic designers in the world here's
how it works
you go to 99designs comm I suggest for /
Tim for reasons I'll explain and whether
you need to create a logo a website a
car rap a bumper sticker whatever it
might be a t-shirt you can put up what
you need a description then designers
around the world compete for your
business by submitting ideas and designs
and so on and in less than a week you
have an original design that you love or
you get all your money back and I have
used 99 designs for years including for
some very big projects like the book
cover or at least brainstorming book
cover ideas for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times bestseller and is in I don't know
dozen plus languages and has sold a
gajillion copies so I have used it when
time and money has been of the essence
it is a fantastic
tool and if you go to 99designs comm
forward slash Tim you can actually see
some of the campaign's some of the
competition's that I've run so actual
submissions for the book covers and
things like that you can also get a $99
upgrade for free which gets you more
submissions so check it out
99designs comm forward slash Tim and now
without further ado please enjoy part 2
the final part of the Tim Ferriss show
with Tony Robbins and to touch on a few
things that you mentioned for those
people asking themselves as I'm sure a
lot of people would how can I apply what
these guys do to what I do and I think
that you you present a number of
observations articulated very very well
that most people will never be exposed
to for instance number one asset
allocation does not mean choosing if you
are going to be a stock picker or invest
in an index fund for the S&P 500 because
as both your your in one bucket that's
right you know you're in a correlated
class that's right and no
diversification of them right there's
more to stuff as risk is anymore
companies but it's all within the same
asset class and the other thing is that
there are ways there are there are ways
to look at the problem that are not
obvious right off the bat for instance
you mentioned something that's so simple
but a lot of people miss if if you
invest and you lose fifty percent you
have to now have a hundred percent gain
to get back to break even put another
way this is also straight from the book
if you let's just say you I think it was
investing over it was either five or ten
years the exact number is in the book
but and you had you'd invested in the
stock market through a let's just call
it sort of off-the-shelf mutual fund
that charges typical fee is yeah and the
market moves up and down up and down up
and down at the end of that period of
time you're back at the same market
levels yes you would think if you put in
a hundred grand you'd be you'd have a
hundred grand at the end of that period
of time and it ends up that you're what
forty-seven percent down for something
obscene it's it's the idea of average
rates of return so if a lot of people
look at their what they've
invested in their their broker or their
whoever represents them will show them
their portfolio go look you know you
went up you started here you want a
fifty percent you would down fifty but
you went up fifty you went down fifty so
your average rate of return is zero but
I put real dollars in there one hundred
thousand dollars and you go up fifty 150
go down fifty you're at 75 you go up 50
oops yeah and then go down and you end
up at $37,000 instead of a hundred
thousand dollars because your principal
is moving up and down so they're all
these ways we could do it the biggest
one the biggest why are you in the book
I want keep these seven steps so one of
those steps is frankly you got to do
what most of us guys probably people
listening on your team already do and
that is you've got to become an
investment you got to be an owner not a
consumer right and the way to do that
frankly we all know but very few people
do and that you take a percentage you
lock it down it you never see it it's
automated and you put it aside for
investment and that just occurs and I
show the people some of the tools that
Nobel Prize winners have come up with so
if you say I have no money you can
invest more for tomorrow by committing
when you get a raise or your company
gets the next level you automatically
have that percentage go there so it's
money you've never seen it's not taking
away money from you so you're willing to
commit to it right and there ways to
automate that totally automate which is
fantastic so you know they took they
took a group of blue-collar workers who
couldn't save more than 3% and they
showed in 12 years and above the 16%
with absolutely no sense of loss because
you know once if I show this with
example of the behaviorists showed me
that if you give a net monkey and Apple
they go crazy you give them two apples
and they go crazy and you take one of
the two apples back they're angry as
hell they still have the same first
Apple what happens is if you don't give
them that second Apple but it gets
invested for them
you know that pit changes your world you
don't feel a sense of loss there's no
drop and yet you set yourself up saving
fifteen sixteen seventy percent a
totally different world than three or
nothing obviously second piece that I
got through that brought this up for is
you got it's great to get in the game
but oh my god don't get in the game to
you I understand the rules till you're
an insider and so I go through the nine
biggest lies there and they're their
investment lies their Wall Street lies
are you want to call them but they're
marketed wise there's a reason you
believe very heavily marketed very
heavily market today they had to try and
one of those is this idea that they're
going to beat the market
now here's the real facts 96% check
about 96% of all mutual funds in a
10-year period will never even match the
market now you're paying a premium you
could have owned an index that cost you
20 basis points right at Vanguard or 14
basis points manwich what index you're
dealing with instead you're paying they
say 1% you ask me what about just 1% in
reality and you go through Forbes of
[ __ ] on the average mutual find when you
put all fees in if you read the
prospectus and there's all these 21 be
trading take all these things that don't
call fees very often but their money out
of your pocket the average is 3.1
percent now when you do that here's the
problem number one only 4% what's your
chance of picking the 4% of mutual funds
they're going to be succeed if you go
through Morningstar you're screwed
because I can show you statistically
more restarts own statistics that show
in a 10-year period of 250 people that
made it to 5 star Morningstar 4 or left
doesn't work that way right so if you
could pick the 4% if you were magically
able to do that you can do all right
but the 4% is always changing so your
chances of picking the right mutual fund
a 96% against you and the average
person's following can't work they don't
know how to evaluate this they try and
pick it so they're screwed and then you
get poor performance and you pay
somewhere between 10 and 30 times more
for the same investment you kind of got
for 30 times the 10 to 30 times less
it's like the ultimate insert injury and
go why does that matter well first let
me give you that so people understand
what 96% means are getting a 4% possible
success rate if you didn't play
blackjack most people not apply right 21
get to face cards that's worth 20 points
if your inner idiot says hit me right
when you've got to face cards go 21 you
have an 8% chance of success you have a
greater chance success there than you
did if you're trying to find the right
mutual fund now what's your chance of
success in getting financially free when
here's what's unbelievable if if I said
to you here's an investment I want you
to try Tim here's how it works you put
up all the money you put up all the risk
and I will put up no money and I put up
no risk and if you win I get up to 60%
of your entire growth of what you have
over the lifetime of your investing you
put a vote
I take no risk I put no money in and if
you lose you lose but I don't lose
anything that's a deal that most people
said I've never taken a million years
that's the average mutual fund because
for every 1% you pay it's 20% over the
lifetime of your investments of growth
because just like there's compounded
brokers compounded thieves right so
Bogle showed me 60% I'm saying Jack
how's this possible how could people be
doing this like you know 30 is the 13
trillion dollar line it's called one
thing marketing yeah this is marketing
so I've been in the business 64 years it
makes me crazy and people still do it
the vast majority people put their money
in a mutual time they had an index
finding out now he's come to you know be
the largest mutual fund in the world
within the next time now two and a half
trillion I mean jack has been modified
but most the smart money is there it's
not the average person's money that's in
the index today so I go through these
lies and what you don't know in the
financial world will hurt you and the
one you're talking about is just the
average rate of return you want to be
seduced when you look at the rate of
return bubble said to me Tony
whenever you see what the rate of return
was here trying to evaluate that mutual
fund based on its past performance just
know that numbers not accurate dowel bar
did an incredible study 20-year study if
I'm the average mutual fund owner over
20-year period of time made 2.5 percent
net the at market was nine point seven
percent that'll give you a sense so you
know I I went to go to this book and I
won't mention the person's name ID all
these incredible endorsements from
everybody Nobel Prize winners right some
big billionaires all these guys there's
particular person that I'm really good
friend of how much today but it was
ironic he wrote me back to when my
team's read it and they really don't
think it's that you know that that's
special and I'll I'm not insulted by
that but it doesn't make sense to me and
then I perhaps person s6 mutual funds
like okay I get a dude done Escobar if
you need air cut my fault never ask that
so I should point out to folks also that
it's some people are very math phobic
part of the reason I went uh to
Princeton as funny I was reading Carl
icons story and how he was he was just
you told he was told he would never get
into any I take schools and he chose
Princeton same thing happened to me I
was told I would never get in to a whole
host of schools because and this is kind
of like your mutual fund guy
humans respond to incentives yes and
this particular guidance counselor is
incentivized for what to optimize to be
able to say X number X percentage of
students got into their first choice
school so how do you do that most easily
whether expectations lower their
expectations but the I am intrinsically
not someone with a lot of math
background pardon reason I chose
Princeton over other schools because
they didn't have a math requirement and
I think for a lot of people listening
they may be like um I got percentages
and compounding odds it's very
overwhelming and I think that part of
the reason your book had to be as long
as it is and book should be as long as
it needs to be yes is that if you were
to try to compress it into 100 pages it
would be like watching a three-hour
action movie but getting a frame every
five minutes yeah you wouldn't it would
be too much in too little space but when
people read the book when I read the
book you're leading people in a logical
progression from building block to
building block to building blocks so
that by the end people are very very
savvy and so people who are who might be
thinking oh my god this is this is
really a lot for me to absorb it's
highly targeted miles now yeah the book
I'm telling you stories to it I think
the stories take it away so it's not
numbered you go holy [ __ ] if if me and
if me and three of my friends all put
aside the same amount of money and we
both get a 7% return but my buddy is
getting fees of 3% my other buddies too
and I'm one and we both put in all three
was put a million bucks in or a hundred
thousand I'm you want to do it ah the
person with three percent of these ends
up with sixty five percent less money
and they got the same rate of return
they'd start with the same amount of
money over the same period of time and I
think when you see that with real
people's lives you start to go I don't
have to know the math I just know one
thing fees matter and I'm going to cut
those babies to the absolute base
definitely and I'd love to talk you you
brought it up a little earlier Ray Dalio
as asset allocation because this is
something I've been thinking about a lot
considering that uh due to paper gains
I'd say I have very very very very high
double digits of my entire net worth in
tech and it's hard unfortunately to
rebalance when you have a lot of private
stock or they can't be traded but you
know it it's that the but uh dolly o
someone I've been fascinated by
for so long maybe you could talk about
the the All Seasons and what some of the
stuff that you that you chatted with him
about as it relates to asset allocation
it might be helpful for people take a
second and get people his background me
Ray's not the guy you would think of his
master the universe he comes from Queens
dad was a jazz musician his mom was a
homemaker really lovely lady
he went from you know very lower
middle-class family and decided that he
wanted to go work at a golf course he
bumped into you know one of things I
talked about his proximity affects your
life we're in proximity with and he's
around with proximity with the very
wealthy people and I'm talking about
stocks and he got fascinated by it and
got hooked on the process and then you
know got involved in stock business and
but he got involved in a time period
when the world was incredibly volatile
the nineteen seventies they were all
shape our time periods right and so he
can imagine you know that's the time we
had this massive inflation where Nixon
goes on television and says we're going
off the gold standard that money as you
know it called the US dollar we're not
going to back up with anything and he
thought for sure the markets would just
be destroyed the American dollars going
to be worthless and instead they had
what was called the Nixon rally and it's
like it shook him to his core that as
much as you think you know you don't
know and it gave him a lifelong focus it
says I always want to be asking what do
I not know and how do I find understand
the system as a whole not just my
perspective on the system and so he
started bridgewater and in fact my
friend Paul Tudor Jones gave him some of
his initial capital do this it is
wishing he didn't loan it to him who
would have kept that as an investment I
think at this stage at Bridgewater gives
so gigantic but what happened was he's
the guy the US government to when
they're trying to figure out a design
tips and this is the level design he's
the guy that when McDonald's trying to
come out with egg made with with
McNuggets and they're trying to figure
out how can we make sure we have enough
supply of chicken and he's the one
figured out the math of futures and what
to do so McDonald's could even do that
that's not the way this man's brain
works so over the years he built this
alpha fund and it's very intensive and
he's lost money in 23 years three times
on that fund and the fund has returned
21 percent compounded for 23 years just
mind-boggling before fees and then turn
around and after all these years he said
you know
he talks about you know difference
things you live you want to protect
yourself so you do a balanced portfolio
50% 60% in stocks maybe in 40 or 50
percent you know here in bonds because
you know when the stocks are more
volatile the bonds are going to balance
you out he says you know but didn't look
that way in 2000 didn't look there do
that ou went down 2008 right so over the
years he said this is a story everybody
buys but it's not reality and a whole
segments of time so he began to pursue
what he said what if I wasn't around I
need a passive almost passive form
investment ain't something that wouldn't
take 1500 people that my kids could use
that you know that would support all my
philanthropic efforts if I wasn't here
and he questioned everything about asset
allocation that anybody's ever been
taught and came up with a different way
of looking at it where he basically said
there are four things that move the
price of any investment its inflation
and deflation and whether the economy is
growing or shrinking and that creates
four different seasons in which every
every type of investment stocks
commodity is gold real estate it has an
ideal environment which it grows and as
environments in which I EPA will
absolutely slam and so he figured out
what's the right combination of these
things so that I can reduce the risk to
the lowest level of loss possible which
you know Warren Buffett's rules
everybody talks about the rule right it
doesn't Warren Buffett's role it
actually comes from his teacher which
was you know rule number one to
investing don't lose money rule number
two see rule number one right so how do
I make that happen but also maximize the
mountain upside as much upside is
possible he called it as all-weather fun
because it works in all weather and he
did all his own investing it for ten
years and he back tested it all the way
to 1925 and said oh my god I have
discovered something of legal so the
only people got to use this is he and
then finally his clients the five
billion dollar net worth the
government's the pension funds so I've
read about it you know rain is very few
interviews as I'm sure you know you
online you won't find a lot you know in
front of the Congress you know maybe it
Davos every now and then he kind of
avoids any publicity and so forth and I
did all my homework on it my you know
Paul Tudor some of his dearest friends
arranged to go see him laid it all out
and I was prepared and then I go into
this meeting and I started asking him I
asked him a question I asked everybody
which was if you can't
you couldn't pass on any your money your
children none all you could pass on was
a set of principles an investment
strategy in a portfolio what would it be
for your kids they don't have your skill
everybody made different answers but his
answer was well-being my all you know
all-weather approach since so explaining
that works explain at the end of it just
like me telling to you right now real
fast you know people probably going I
don't have a clue he just said it seems
logical but the one thing he said is
Tony is when people think they got a
balanced portfolio stocks are three
times more volatile than bonds so when
you're 50/50 you really 90 10 yep you
really are massively at risk and that's
why when the markets go down you get
eaten alive so he has this portfolio
describes principle I said I said you
know what ready this is spectacular I
understand it but he said the only way
you really get the result from this is
if you know the exact percentages it's
like if you got if you got some his
recipe and you put in a gallon when they
put in a teaspoon for particular
ingredient you're messed up so I said I
need the secret sauce yeah and he looks
at me laughs he goes Tony yeah yeah
that's my business and that's what he
gave me the whole five billion dollar
net worth and you know gotta have a
hundred billion I said yeah right but
you just got to tell him you I'm taking
anybody's money for 10 years you're not
gonna take it these money goes yeah but
you know it's really complex and I said
I know it is but give me a simple
version he said no you know it's always
changing I said give me a version with
no leverage at the average person to do
you just got done telling me then go
into the broker go into their wealth
manager and you know going through
mutual funds not gonna work so help a
little guy out I know you care and I
started teasing us come on you know give
me the Jews start laughing as well he
said I could give you something wouldn't
be perfect I said I don't want perfect
your worst design will be the best
design anybody else ever come up with
right so I gotta go he said well we
might be any lays out this simple
strategy
I was vibrating I was like vibrating
just I could I knew what a generosity
level was it was unbelievable
he's never revealed it to anyone in
history and I ran as fast as I could I
got in the helicopter flew back went to
the guys at Hightower went to the guys
at that two of the firms and I said I
want you to run these numbers show me
the modern period show me the last 30
years what really happened with this
formula every single year for 30 years
and what's the overall for the 30 years
cuz that's I look at 30 years 1984 you
know that's when we finally had
cell phones even right when the world
starts chef show me 40 years and show me
75 years take me back right before the
depression even right and the guy the
guy texted me and I know the night he
never texted me and he says have you
seen the numbers as I'll ever forgot I
get up a call on the phone see black now
I'm seeing him emails them to me
and Ray was right 85 to 86 percent of
time every time period we look at
between 85 and 86 30 years 40 years 75
years would that mean and by the way
that's being liberal because the 15
percent where he lost money the most he
ever lost is three point nine five
percent in 75 years and that was 2008
when the market was peak to trough was
down 51 percent the average loss
including that was 1.9 percent
so like for example you know one of his
losses point zero three I mean really
was breakeven but we called it a loss
because it's technically it's a loss if
you could go to Vegas and you knew that
for 75 years the strategy you used had
been successful 85 percent of the time
and that when you lost the most you loss
of one point nine percent how much would
you bet how long would you it you know
continue to gamble and there's hard to
figure it out so I mean I mismatched I
took it I took it to some very large
institutions than like I've ever seen
like this so a couple people said to me
you know this let's this don't put this
in the book this is good this is a
business man this is a business Isel
this will give you the lowest of all
volatility the highest level return an
average is just under 10 percent return
with that little volatility it's
mind-boggling so I said you know what
that's not the spirit of a Sheraton
I said you know we can do this for
people they want to do and get that
option but I'm putting the book so
anybody can do it and it's in the book
right then and there and yeah it's not
the only one there's strategy so that's
one of the more exciting ones that
you'll see is there anything to live to
you but just is there anything you can
share from what what he told you about
the all weather well the I mean I will
just say as a preface list there's so
much in this book number one I've had
also people say to me for instance I'm
not going to name any my close friends
but like a 4-hour body blow that's fine
give me the index card and so I know and
I give them the index card and there's
there's context missing exactly and they
also it's not just because they can't in
some cases do extra missing the
they won't do it so get the book do
yourself a favor I'm not holding back on
I might damp okay the reason I wouldn't
share that is because it'll be out of
context but even in the book I tell
people the first chapter I tell them
this result I have one example I said I
know the first thing I want to do is
turn back to that section of work and I
said you can do it but I caution you
there's a syntax there's a sequence the
dog vijaya up the dog and if you will go
through the sequence it's going to be
more if you know that portfolio but you
don't know truthfully what your risk
tolerance is you don't know truly what
your personal goals are you don't know
what you need to avoid on the fee
structure and the tax structures then
that return won't be very great for you
and more importantly you won't go
through the psychology it'll make you
actually follow through for a while but
if people want to do it by the way I
then went to Hightower which is the
fifth largest restaurant festive
advisory in the United States thirty
billion in assets thirteen
fastest-growing inc magazine company
fastest growing company mazing elliott -
CEO blown away about his mana did an
interview of them and I left there going
this man is committed to total
transparency this man blows out all
those fees all the to Santa in this
nicest way possible screwing over that
happens to most clients he eliminates
that he's a former litigator he's got a
moral code that's pretty intense I loved
him so I came back and I called him up
and so let's meet again I met again and
I said you know how I got to challenge
you I said how about you do this for
everybody else if we talk about I said
how about for the average man that
really needs it so when you talk about
said bring that ultra-wealthy advice to
them show them on a small scale how they
what they do what you're ultra wealthy
client doesn't ghost why you can't make
money doing that so you don't need to
make money doing it
I'm gonna doing a book of a million
money doing that's it a part of our life
has to be for something more and I said
I know that's what you're about I said
but I'm not taking about putting your
business at risk I said let's use
technology technology would like people
the balance and so we built together a
site I put them together with this group
called stronghold which is brilliant
they've been managing my money for me
for applause seven years Ajay Gupta he's
actually the person that Charles Schwab
put on the cover of most magazines for
the last year as kind of the face of the
10,000 interested investment visor II
fiduciaries around the world and on the
country and the two of them got together
create the site it's kind of like check
your broker so now you can go online and
you can put in all your accounts it will
aggregate them it's a pack
technology get to see a what your real
costs are on everything all in one
picture
there's nobody s versus what you could
have the same investments for right
right it's like why would I pay more
second thing it does it shows you what
your real returns have been combined
what first what you think they are and
third it shows you what your ball to we
loves with the amount of risk you're
taking so you know and then fourthly it
does a comparison to that versus other
portfolios including the one designed by
great value and you can go wow do I want
to do this if if you're a person like
half the US less than 25,000 vessel
assets you get to do the whole thing for
free it's given to you go do it if you
are not you know more but you can still
do it for it you do it yourself or you
can push a button and say I like you to
become my wrenched investment visor if
somebody can do it so I got to do it
saying mostly people you're never going
to see anything from but wealthy people
started not wealthy right right and so
it's really cool it's one of those few
recordings that sounds win-wins right
these guys are adding value I got him to
do it and now they're proud of it
excited about it so it's a cool thing so
what is it URL the URL is uh it's what
stronghold financial.com I got a double
check my pretty guess it will double
check that and also go in the show notes
guys you got uh you're saying to answer
my question I don't want cut you off Oh
a lot of questions well you don't want
uh you know let me highlight a couple
things oh you're into question I said
I'm not gonna I don't wanna come here
cuz even the book I don't do it you get
there won't mean anything to you I'm not
holding anything back you know the
bookstore open up and read it not pay
today I don't give a [ __ ] but I think
you'd be doing yourself a disservice we
you really want to do is take yourself
to the process so that when you get to
that point you can decide do I want that
value to be twenty percent of what I do
five percent ten percent nine fifty
because there are many different
strategies in the book including as you
said David Swensen David Swensen is the
most successful institutional investor
of all time from Yale
he went from 1 billion took their monies
from 1 billion to twenty point nine
billion twenty four billion now in two
decades he's a rock star nicest human
being you'll ever meet in your life and
doesn't get paid one-tenth the rest
these guys it's his dedication to Yale
was why he's there I mean you leave
there of you totally different place
when he had cancer
the man said listen I'm not going
anywhere this is my bucket list is to be
here and to continue to serve at Yale
as such unbelievable integrity and he
gave me his exact portfolio that's in
the book also and he actually gets a
higher return to even idea the Ray does
but you have to go through a lot more
volatility obviously so that's why your
risk you see what I got to know what
your real yeah what you think your risk
reward is in your mindset versus what it
really is you'll know when you go to the
book if I can make a request yes I would
love for you to interview the guy who
hired Swenson for Yale cuz talk about
the best hire of all time no kidding I
mean just the psychological profile on
the guy's so unique yeah
this a couple things I'd love to to just
underscore for folks the first is and
and again this is pulling stuff from the
book I'm going to paraphrase some of it
but I think it was Dalia who said
something along the lines of like losers
react winners anticipate actually me but
also cuz you get to rebuild I know but
but the point being that the and I guess
Mark Twain quote is also in there which
was what history doesn't repeat itself
but it rhymes yeah so there are going to
be crashes there are going to be Black
Swan events and you want to have a plan
in place for when that happens second
and the more you can automate your many
of your financial decisions now no one
to hold them no one fold them and
actually have a plan going in so if you
buy something and have no plan for
selling it you're going to be subject to
sort of impulse reactions that will
cause you to do it the vast majority of
people do they they buy high and they
sell low so what is in this with what
we're talking about when we talk about
asset allocation among other things just
in sort of try to try to distill it for
people as a concept is that you have
uncorrelated or inversely correlated
buckets so that if if one portion of
your investments goes down because of
inflation deflation fill-in-the-blank
there are others that go up which
mitigate your risk let's go and what you
notice and I live in Silicon Valley I'm
very involved with tech that's that sort
of in my sandbox for the last close to
ten years I guess and what you notice
about the bet three ninety five percent
so talk about venture capital hat is
very similar to mutual
so it's the vast majority are horrible
as a class they're terrible
however if you if you pick the unicorns
and you use the same term there are read
off learners yeah yeah they're a handful
who are very very consistent and so what
I've tried to do just like you did with
a lot of these hedge fund managers is
look at what separates them and what
separates them is you have the the vast
majority of tech investors who think a
high-risk high-return I've got a swing
for the fences I'll be okay as long as a
third of my startups lose money a third
break even and a third make money well
it wouldn't be like nice if life work
though yeah it does it doesn't work that
way whereas whereas the whereas the guys
were really good realize that there's a
power-law distribution one or two of
their investments are going to make up
for all of the losses and the very top
of the top even though they'll talk
about it publicly if they have a lot of
their personal money at play have
thought a lot about asset allocation so
if they're heavily vested in tech and it
might have an IPO globo they have they
have an entire basket of shorts on the
Nasdaq or whatever it might be
so that by the way it's not always
high-risk high-reward if their tech goes
to hell they have enough money that is
betting it's going to go to hell that
they don't lose a lot of money if at all
or maybe they've make me that's absolute
true and so I think the it's get a way
of doing that you mentioned I think your
brain may have been going this direction
maybe I'm wrong but Ray Dalio actually
said something in there that stuck with
me brutally he said I don't care what it
is that you think you're great at
investing in or you like most people
invest in what they like real estate or
stocks or bonds what they think they're
good at or what they were raised with he
said whatever asset class you invest in
I promise you in your lifetime it will
drop no less than 50 a more likely 70%
at some point and he said that is why
you absolutely must diversify because
you're saying but I can make so much
more in this side you know I've had
people throughout the years I teach this
market theory this idea that you want to
do is make a sonication simple it sounds
like such a big word yeah it's just
buckets some way money is going to go in
a secured bucket that bucket is like a
church people I'm going to it's not
going away
it's very secure type investments it's
upside is not gigantic in terms of speed
but you know what the compounding
process if you give enough time those
low returns are giant returns though but
you're not gonna lose and then there's
this bucket called what most people call
growth bucket I call risk growth because
it's really risk first yeah and I'm at
I'm taking bigger risks for potentially
greater rewards and now the question is
how do i balance these am i 6040 5050
80/20 and that's designed really by
three things number one what your real
dispeller it's not what you think it is
yeah and they're not in the same they
know to say you know I do it I do these
wealth mastery programs in a few years
and variably I'll do some crazy thing
like I'll say everything up make change
they look at me go make change and they
start reaching their pockets and they
can change that's something to pull out
five bucks and ten bucks see some people
in a hundred dollars and know someone
come up and they'll take it and give
them five bucks and they're like you
know they don't how to react so this
goes on for three or four minutes the
music's going on okay stop right sit
down are they going like I'm talking
about something else and invariably
somebody's like hey wait a second I want
my I want my hundred dollars back so
what are you talking about they said I
want minded always like the game's over
I said what do you think the game was
over you think the game had ever gone
over right and who said it was your
hundred dollars Yeah right and it's low
it takes a while worth fight they
finally get you know I'm stressed about
a hundred dollars what do think is gonna
happen when you lose a million or half a
million or a hundred thousand or ten
grand I mean your risk tolerance is not
we thinking of so when we find out your
responses and we got great ways to do
down the book and then you figure out
really how much time do you have if
you're younger you got more time to make
mistakes and so you can take bigger
risks you know you got timeline on your
product is four and then another next
piece is how much is your cash flow
what's that that's going to be the real
fun if you look at those three things
now you can decide how much goes in my
secure bucket how much goes my growth
and if you don't make that decision it's
the most important investment decision
of your life recording everybody I
interviewed like what percentage secure
what percentage growth at risk then when
things come up you're always going to go
for the growth risks it looks so sexy
and exciting and I can't tell you how
many people over the years have done
this they're telling me why when I put
money over here when I've got this real
estate I'm making a hundred twenty
percent of a friend that don't some of
the first big condos in Vegas back in
the boom time
and he he activated my programs sold the
business he had made two hundred million
dollars and
in these condos started building the
panorama towers and places that nature
and he was up there like three quarters
of building I kept saying them dude
take some of your growth money and put
it in a secure bucket right and how many
times I told you this goes tone I love
you I made two hundred million dollars
gives you but now I'm you know I'm
really like what I touch goes the golden
listeners ego too but I love your
brother but I said you know many times
of the conversation and then guess what
happens in 2008 how much you think he
like he was worth three quarters of a
billion dollars he grown that rapidly in
those short ears we think happened to
his network I'm guessing it went down
according to the Ray Dalio prediction
about minus 400 million oh he didn't
just lose what he had he lost everything
out of beyond so then he's trying to
negotiate he wasn't surprised he was
leveraged why is leverage I wiped
himself out so most people don't put
enough in the security bucket is the
lesson and a guy like value provides you
a strategy that's got great
sustainability but there are many
approaches in the book but you do have
to decide how much is secure how much is
growth and I show you how to do that and
I would emphasize at least I'd be
curious hear your thoughts Tony but for
me it took me a long time to think to
realize what investing represents for me
and it's not maximizing return it's
maximizing quality of life yes and
there's a big difference yes and they
did it then for me at least I've very
kind of barbell strategy where I have
super super stiffs safe stuff and then
the the startup stuff but I need to
modify that I want to modify that
because it's not currently yeah all
seasons I don't and the super people out
there I think who might say I you know I
don't want to think about it I would
just emphasize that you're making
decisions every day about where you
allocate your time your money your
resources so whether or not you want to
call yourself an investor you are an
investor toward Rupe and if you make no
decision that's also decision so it's
it's important to become literate I
think with a lot of these basic concepts
which is not difficult one months think
day about that people need to remember
that everybody is a financial trader but
most people are making a bad trade
there's a trading time for money yeah
worst trade of your life because you get
more time we all know it so what this
book will do if you're
just give yourself a chapter a day for a
month or go crazy on a weekend you'll go
from maybe not even knowing what these
term cells are complex to being juiced
because you'll be an insider you will
look at the world in a totally different
way you'll go that is the biggest ripoff
on earth that will ever happen to me
that is where I want to go you'll make
some decisions and then it's not an
everyday thing literally you might do
rebalancing once a year for 15 minutes I
mean unless you're going to be a trader
every day this shouldn't dominate your
life but you when did you give yourself
the initial education about one of the
most important heirs your life there's
only a few areas that really impact the
quality of your life your body your
emotions your relationships your
finances your career your business the
spiritual side of your life and how you
use your time about a half-dozen or cell
maybe seven areas that really affect you
the most people major and minor things
they know so much more about [ __ ] that
doesn't matter yes I'm saying to people
give yourself the gift I'm just a short
burst of time so that you can truly look
at life and be good at this area and if
you want something to do it for you can
but at least then you lead them you're
not being led by them right no
definitely and I think that you know
just like one of the things that sort of
changed my world and startup investing
was you know any company you invest in
should be able to return the fund just
as like a general the amount of money
that you're investing over X number of
years and just like these sort of $1 to
$5 yeah principle with Tudor Jones and
they're they're a couple of pithy
heuristics like rules of thumb that I
think will change how you view not just
money or stocks but the world in general
such as assume in the the Dahlia case
that you know your favorite area your
kind of pet investment bucket is going
to decrease by at least 50% in the next
you know experts not 77 50 to 70 even
better
73 certain yeah and in plan accordingly
yeah and I think that yeah it's been a
very very fun process to read this and
also to connect with you over it
let me ask if I could because I know
you've gotten you've got a lot planned
and I also want to finish up the last
few interviews in the in the book
reading the ones that you did I'm
curious is there any any particular
funny stories
what was the funniest story or
interaction you had while researching
and writing this book that comes to mind
well I think you share what I'm already
I think is who the it's funny now it
wasn't a funny in the moment is walking
at Carl icons office so excited so
prepared ready to rip open cuz this guy
he's got the greatest returns of anybody
out there under a few people know that
Kiplinger did the first review that
really showed all the numbers I mean if
you'd invest in him in 1968 you'd have a
31 percent compounded return within his
firm versus at Buffett's firm you'd have
a 20 percent return people think of
Buffett is the ultimate guy so I got
these facts figures I'm excited and to
have him literally throwing my video
crew out the door and then telling me no
audio and I'm like how the hell am I
going to keep up with this guy capture
the note so that be one a fun moment was
introducing Carl Icahn to Jack Bogle
they didn't know each other and they're
fans of each other so it's like I came
from being an outsider to now
introducing them but most of the time of
these guys wasn't as much funny as it
was fascinating
he was just seeing the level of the they
played the games like with a great poker
player you know they know the psychology
they know the numbers they know the
probability and you just realize why
most people are never going to win
because you know they're not going to
win gold medals against these guys that
are playing this game day and night
night and day you know so some of that
is an enemy just because Paul's been my
dearest friend for you know 21 years now
but it's it's fascinating to see that in
every in every industry in every sport
there are a few players that play at the
highest level and they have one thing in
common above all else hunger but it's an
unquenchable hunger you have that hunger
I see that I knew that's why I'm a fan
of your work it's like you're going to
keep finding the answer to matter
whenever you got one no more and every
one of these people has that and it's
fun to be around them because there's
energy and every one of these people
they have different styles but there's
an energy and that energy is driven by
that desire that hunger to know more and
the other observation and that was
reinforced by reading the book was that
they also they have principles they have
operating systems that they use and
whether you are trying to lose weight
trying to quit smoking trying to improve
your investment returns you can insure
against your lesser instincts by
having a system putting systems in place
so that when you have the impulses that
are going to lead to your destruction or
eating the cupcake when you should need
it because that you can mitigate against
that and it's possible you can set these
things up in advance uh I would love to
before we wrap up just ask a couple of
rapid-fire questions sure go for it okay
uh when you think of the word successful
who's the first person that comes to
mind gosh I like Richard Branson I know
why that's first thing popped my head
when you said that only because I think
he lives so passionately he lives life
on his terms there's no [ __ ] with
him he's having a good time as close to
his family lives on an island like I do
I guess I like but he's an extraordinary
leverage and very conscious man about
society and what to do he's elders
program and things like that he's very
socially conscious and yet still has a
great time so you'll be one of the first
people I think of probably what have you
changed your mind about over the years
any positions you've taken that you've
that you've reversed since you don't
have to be perfect in everything you do
including not eating anything enjoyable
try to be a big with my right foot tell
you gosh you know over the years there's
you're always updating I mean I don't
look at it as changing as much as
updating and informing myself you know
if you thought of it as changing I think
you'd find resistance within your own
consciousness or your own identity and
you know identity play such a strong
wall the need to be consistent with what
you believe and that's why the political
system is so messed up you know somebody
can actually grow and they're seen as
inconsistent yeah it's in that it makes
the political system not grow it makes
the system walked in place so I don't
look think there's think comes to mind
just real directly but I think it's
there's a constant upgrading and
sometimes it's those Tillamook to move
either upgrades that provide the biggest
impact yeah
side note for folks that's also common
among the top venture capitalist
investors Marc Andreessen who created
the graphical web browser hit one of his
mottos for andreessen horowitz is strong
opinions weekly held so he's he's ready
to be corrected or update as you
mentioned what would people be surprised
to know about you um gosh she says my
wife that question
I don't know some people would not
despise all people in my events when I'm
a Love Bug I'm a kind of guy that I can
be brought to tears by seeing someone do
the right thing just and yet I'm you
know I've run through that wall shake
the building with 10,000 people in it
I'm a softy really truly underneath it
all that's what drives all this at me
okay I love to see people lit up I love
to see people happy I love to see people
freed so I'm going to ask an unusual one
given that answer what's the first face
that comes to mind when you think
punchable vegetable oh my gosh well I
had an interesting meeting with
President Obama actually at jigglets it
was I was invited by Marc Benioff to
come it was for I don't know 15 of the
billionaires there in Silicon Valley I
was in San Jose and it was for the
president it was before the second
election his reelection and I voted for
the president you know so I've been a
fan of the president but I was getting
more and more frustrated by watching the
style of politics which was you know
creating great and greater division and
there's it seem to me a great level and
accuracy and the promises being made
that very hard not to see and at that
time it was the whole thing we're going
to raise taxes on the rich and that's
going to balance the budget and I've
done the numbers I did a whole video on
it shows you can kill every rich person
United States and take all their money
and take all the corporations and all
the advertising from the Super Bowl I
mean I do this whole long gig that came
from some statistics another man put
together for me but I did together and
you can't cover the budget for one year
and then what you do next year right and
so I said to mark I said listen I've
supported the president but I said
honestly I don't know I can support the
other side but I don't know that I'm a
guy to be there I don't know that I'm a
fan and mark I said mark you and I are
so aligned and so much but you know the
way in which you know how simpson-bowles
was this close and he let it pass we had
both sides willing to make some tough
decisions is beyond me that just it
lacks the leadership that fundamentally
the president States in my mind has to
have that's my judge but not just a
person but it's like I don't understand
who's taking the easy route is not
something that's going to sustain or
grow this economy long term and I said
and and
using the political capital even though
I'm supportive healthcare using that
healthcare where half the country is
upset about it and pushing it down their
throat and trying to say it's going to
cost less money and it's just like
there's certain things so much as I
agree with you like Mediamark is the
second largest fundraiser for the
president so I said well then how about
you raise all the money goes well
because I feel stronger about him than
the other guy and he said and you and I
are lined with him on so many other
things about you know the environment
and you know you know people's right to
marriage regardless of their sexual
preference and I said of course we are
so he said come come and be there I said
I said you know me I'm totally
respectful but I'm honest he goes come
he said I'll set you right next to the
president he said we'll have a great
conversation I went to this this meeting
and it was crazy I mean I've worked so
many presents over the years but I not
throw the bottle that's downtown San
Jose did they locked everybody in their
buildings and literally you know it
looked like one of those movies you know
what everybody's died there's nothing
left but the buildings it was the
wildest thing for several blocks took us
up in this room there's nobody else
theaters these 16 people many but you
know from Silicon Valley and I listened
and presen came in it was really
wonderful and he shared you know some
comments and said I'm not here give a
speech I'm here you guys have built the
biggest companies in the world I think
I'm not me I don't fit that category and
so I was going to say anything he said
but I really want to hear from you guys
so mark turns dim and says well yeah are
you ready for some you know real
give-and-take Express when he said yeah
he goes okay who wants to go first and
he points straight at me hahaha that's
what friends are for
so I said mr. president I said I've
paused
I literally pause that I shouldn't do
this I'm not here they've all paid a
quarter million bucks to be here I
actually never knows where I went
thousand one thousand ten DeCinces if
somebody else is going to say some l3f I
said okay so one mr. president I said I
said I really want you know I voted for
you I know you even have tremendous
integrity I share the same values you do
I believe but I said I'm really confused
about two things number one how you
think you'll be able to have a you know
a second four-year run and get anything
done when you have taken the other side
and demonize them to a point that
they're never going to work with you and
my second question if I ever get one
would be why don't you support
some balls right I said it was right
there need to be done and a nice long
pause they said well those are fair
questions and he said is the first of
all I don't think I've ever demonized
the other party ever I just happened and
I watched him saying I was like are you
kidding me I'm not a Republican but come
on all right you know both sides of
demonize a kid and he goes and they've
been really unfair to me any went to
this piece and I said mr. president
that's happened with every president
right there you know that's that's what
they both do and it's gotten worse
throughout the years for sure I said but
what about simpson-bowles and he said
well Tony any every years of research
about who's in the room the president
knew he was well Tony you know your
friends your hedge fund friends he said
you know they wouldn't like it if we got
rid of you know the 15% do you know tax
they do in Halon and he goes in you know
most Americans would like if they got
rid of their mortgage deduction and you
know those things and he said I got a
better plan I said the better plan is
you're going to raise taxes back to Bush
on the wealthy and I said it takes four
billion dollars a day to run this
country and you know as well as I do the
estimates of all that money in won't
even cover three months of this
government spending so it won't solve it
you have to raise taxes on everyone to
cover this I said so how do you do that
and so he and I went back and forth and
to be fair I'm telling my version the
story I'm sure he gave it a version
story but there's a point where I was I
felt I'm losing rapport with every
person in this room but I had to be
honest and and finally at one point six
years became her and grabbed my wrist he
said I think that's enough
and the president's I wouldn't didn't
raise my voice the president's you know
to honor him he said no Tony he's
created some creative tension here and
he said I'm not used to that in these
rooms but he said it's fair question I
said you know first no I just want to
know because I voted for you and a lot
of people I know that voted for you I
don't know if they will again I don't
know if they need you're gonna win
anyway yeah but I'd really love to know
what to tell them about how you're going
to govern with this level of division
and so at the end I just said well thank
you for time and then everybody else got
up and asked the questions like will you
give a shout to the Jews and things like
that it doesn't have no hard balls in
there at all but you know it's a
political environment so afterwards I
thought oh my god or he's gonna hate me
and the Reid Hoffman walks up to me you
know from LinkedIn and says I can't
believe you asked him that question
I can't believe you asked him that he
said I've been wanting to asking that
question for every set out good on you
now people come up to me yummy goo and
then the president came around and we
came back around let's shake every
sandwich my aunt I shook his hand I
grabbed him with both hands and I both
can close to me as a mr. president I
said I'm not some stupid Republican
who's just looking for some tax break I
said you know this week I fed a quarter
million people in San Jose I don't live
here I came to an event this is what I
do wherever I go I came from nothing but
I don't forget where I've come from I
care as much as you care but I said I'm
really concerned about your ability to
get your agenda done in the next season
of your career if you don't find a way
to bridge of communication style with
these people intelligence is not enough
you've got to build relationship he
stared at me and he said how about you
weren't likeif cheeky chief of staff and
you come visit me the White House you
and I 101 for an hour I was like blown
away I thought you know I didn't reach
him at all wasn't mind boggling so
Marcos right there he goes that was
unbelievable that was about I love that
you're more clever I love seeing that
that energy back and forth you can
really help so then about a week later
they were getting ready to these debates
and the other side called me and asked
me if I would work with their particular
candidate privately and I'm not
one-sided I want to see a debate that's
real so I work with mr. Romney and
that's the first debate they went in and
he did pretty well and my invitation was
no longer extended so I wouldn't say
punch them out but I'd say frustrated
because here's a man who has such
integrity president States and I think a
classic human being who cares deeply
smart as a whip but it's you know the
failure to find a way to bridge
compromise is both sides responsibility
but in my mind as a citizen I think the
person that States has got to make that
happen under presidents have done that
presidents inhabit and I think that's
not his fault but we're at an impasse
politically that is not allowing us to
do the things that I think are necessary
for our you know put our house in order
in this country and easy for an outsider
see it but as a system we all the right
to opinion so I don't know think punch
but I'd say shaken Network you know
might be better wow that's a hell of a
story I one last question
and
I think people are really going to enjoy
this and I can't wait to see the
comments of the questions also I have my
moments of doubt dark moments I don't
know if you have those those those
moments of doubt yourself and never what
what do you what do you do when you have
those those there's dips when you have
those those down moments and those
moments those moments I've experienced
primarily when I found an inner conflict
that's hard to resolve and that was been
in the past when I'm travel around the
world you know I feel like I'm made to
do what I do is human being I'm certain
that the only human can help people but
I'm able to have a lot of people and I'm
filled it's a privilege and it's a it's
a gift and something that's earned and
something that is part of grace and and
yet I had the greatest thing in my life
outside of my work and my family is my
wife and ironically when I met her she
had extreme motion sickness since birth
and I spent almost a decade going
everywhere she would throw up on we
never want to be a part and she would
throw up on the flight up and on the
flight down and she literally lost I
don't knows 19 pounds when she couldn't
lose her sight zero I took her to every
type of physician I took it every kind
of natural healer acupuncturist I took
her to NASA take expert there nobody's
that will help I took her to the guy who
works the Top Gun pilots because if they
lose their particular system you know
they're dead so they had the system he's
the only one to help her like maybe ten
percent of time not throw up but the
process she did this tightening her body
created a constriction of lymph fluid
and she developed a tumor and so the
darkest days are you know what I think
I'm made here to do and is hurting the
person I love most or I got to be a part
and you know accordi as it sounds I just
I just believed that there was a larger
lesson that I need to find a way to
break through and we finally did and she
no look she doesn't love motion but you
know every throws up on any flight it
was ironically an experience in India
which I'm so bogus to me but I
experienced it she's never thrown up
since that time is mind-boggling this
man who's he doesn't he's not have any
particular faith that's called oneness
and he does this for meditation work
where it basically
your brain to a certain way of being and
it balanced her body out just amazing
but the point of the matter is I went
through all this pain all this question
all this doubt but I kept asking what's
right what's real and I trusted my gut
even when it was painful to trust my gut
and I found that that's probably the
most useful thing the other thing you
got to do is it sounds stupid hydrate
your ass off make sure you rest because
in a lowered state of energy you'll
doubt everything and in the worst thing
can happen if you are what I call energy
rich if you are physiologically at a
peak you can slam anything against you
and you'll know and so that's not to say
you won't have those downs but that's
what I tried to do put my body back in
the strongest place that'll put your
mind back there your heart is always
there and then ask what's right and live
it and you're going to still make
mistakes and when you do I think it's
being forgiving yourself and learning
from it and moving now on to what's next
as quickly as you can so that that
experience allows you to help other
people and for me the worst events I've
ever gone through my life have always
been the best events because I figured
if I'm experiencing this someone else's
too and if I figure it out I can help
millions of people and that's giving me
sanity so I'm not just dealing my pain
or [ __ ] or whether the case may be
enough that's a big part of my life is
ending suffering which is impossible but
ending it in areas of people's life is
possible and you know it's like I always
say it was corny you know you know
suffering is optional paying pain you
know everything got pain in the life but
suffering is optional and I really
believe I can help people get out that
more importantly than get out of a
suffering is give them an experience and
more than joy that's already inside them
and I live to see that light in their
eyes and I'm going to look forward to
seeing at you at some point edit that
because you'll have an experience of it
it won't be this discussion discussions
wonderful experience ten times but I
always tell people you know a belief is
a poor substitute for an experience all
right you can believe all you want about
what you think something is or best
thing is or what China is like we go to
China get the experience go leave it
then you'll know and I'm a big guy on
put people in the experience as quick as
they can and let their spirit and their
heart and their soul kind of take over
and that's what my life's about it's a
good mission it's an amazing mission uh
where can people learn more about the
book more Matt you where would you like
them to come visit I'll give you the
address but you can go to
robin's calm that's the easiest way and
the book again is called money mastered
the game seven simple steps to financial
freedom and what I'll do is I'll give
you a site and if people decide to do
this and they go to Amazon if they'll
send me the receipt I will give them
something I did for people during the
publication period which is I've made
three videos that are kind of a fast
track so somebody's got like 600 pages
seems like a lot to me well here's this
will get you going I think for a lot of
people the audio-video approach is a
good approach to them and then it'll
take them deeper in the book but I do
want you to know that most people I
don't know if you're experienced of this
most we read the book are entertained
because it isn't just like some heavy
factual piece it's take it takes you on
a journey and it's a journey to
financial world which is wild weird
crazy stuff happening it's a journey of
the lives of people that started with
nothing that are the wealthiest people
in the world how he did it and your own
journey about where you going to take
yourself from this point on and how do
you want to live that life and
experiences that you want to not only
have for yourself but what you really
want to give and and that's the greatest
thing I I look back and you think about
money money is nothing but a tool that
you either use for a life of service and
a life increase the quality of life for
yourself with the people you love or
it's used on you as a weapon and I'm big
on saying time for it to no longer be a
weapon used against you and the only way
to do that is educate yourself and you
can do it in a way that's really fun and
that's what this is oh absolutely
so guys check out the book check out
Tony Tony you've had a huge impact on my
life and just to the entertainment
aspect of the book I have tons of books
sent to me I mean dozens a week as I'm
sure you do huge stack a lot of the
questions that I asked did not require
me to read the book and I ended up
pushing off a half dozen important
projects of mine because I got pulled
into the book and I remember I emailed
you and I said you know it's been 20
years you still have it hot damn like I
that feeling the sort of the Tony
Robbins response that I had reading your
material back in high school and
remember you emailed me you're like high
school how old are you it's it's a
really fascinating read and I know some
of you listening or my friends are deep
in the world of Finance you will find
things
in whether it's in the interviews at the
back the profile some of the you know
the top performers over the last several
decades or within it's it's a really
fascinating romp with lots of good
stories so Tony thank you so much for
taking the time thanks for coming down
great to meet your person finally
definitely hope it's not the last very
wealthy brother thanks thank you thank
you for supporting the sponsors of this
show I've used them I like them and I
think you will too
99designs comm phone / Tim it's the
world's largest marketplace of graphic
designers you can see the projects that
I've put up the competition's that I've
spearheaded including the book cover of
4-hour body and you can also get a $99
upgrade for free so check it out at 99
designs com forward slash Tim of course
you can subscribe to this show on iTunes
you can also find every other episode in
the show notes links from this episode
at for our blog.com that's fo u Rho u r
BL og calm and is click on podcast
there's all sorts of other cool stuff
including my interactions with people
like Warren Buffett Mike Shinoda Linkin
Park the list goes on and on and on and
I would love your feedback let me know
what you thought of this show who would
like to hear on the show next and any
other thoughts really you can find me at
twitter @ @ t ferrus that's twitter.com
/t fer Riss and on facebook at
facebook.com forward slash Tim Ferriss
with two R's and two S's until next time
thank you for listening
you